happy
tuesday america and i mean all of you
except for fox and friends
do you see i want my bathrobe back and
my luther vandross cds
so last week the biden administration
finally admitted the president was being
a total
when he accused border patrol agents of
whipping illegal immigrants
those were the actual words
totaled
the head of the border patrol announcing
the results of their absurd months-long
investigation into an incident that both
the dems and the media used to demonize
innocent agents
after an extensive review the us
attorney
issued their decision
not to prosecute the case opr found no
evidence border patrol agents involved
in this
incident struck any person with their
reigns intentionally or otherwise
thanks for the heads up chris
but we could have told you that on day
one those claims were already debunked
by everyone including the guy who took
the damn pictures what a waste of
taxpayer money and all cover their asses
but i got two words for you instant
replay they use it in sports to clear up
a questionable call and this one wasn't
even questionable even the migrants said
don't you dopes know how horses work
but a second look should have cleared up
any confusion immediately like an nfl
ref upon further review the reigns of
the officers never made contact with the
illegal immigrants therefore there is no
unnecessary roughness call
please reset the clock to 2016.
so
oh yeah
but instead the dumbest president in
history
smeared american citizens who were just
doing the job he refused to do while he
sat in a pool of his own ignorance
among other fluids
to see people treat it like they did
horses barely running them over people
being strapped it's outrageous i promise
you those people will pay and as we all
know it also evoked images of some of
the worst moments of our history where
that kind of behavior has been used
against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african-americans
during times of slavery saw horrifying
images that do not reflect who we are
who we aspire to be or the integrity and
values of our truly heroic personnel in
the department of homeland security the
horrific video of the cbp officers on
horse on horses using brutal and
inappropriate measures against innocent
people
once again all of these
are wrong
but more important none of them
apologized or even owned up to it of
course kamala still hasn't apologized
for her tweet defending race hoaxer
justice millet and joe never apologized
for the tweet he tried to send from his
toaster oven
they're just gonna gonna assume you're
too distracted panicking you with the
latest monkey pox baboon aroids or
chymphyzima
sounds like a good drink
they think they won't be held
accountable
and the sad thing is they're right and
they're laughing at us
you can hear kamala's cackle
either that or somebody punched a hyena
so they deserve no mercy tonight and
here's why joe biden publicly condemned
an american without any due process
something no president should ever do
kamala compared border patrol agents to
slave owners
how is that not hate speech how does
that not put a target on their backs
sorry lady if there's anyone with a link
to slave owners it's someone named
kamala
harris
and i'm just quoting
her dad professor donald harris who
wrote quote my roots go back within my
lifetime to paternal grandmother miss
christie descendant of hamilton brown
who was on record as plantation and
slave owner
of brownstown which is the town of
jamaica
who knows if that's true really but if
it is that would make kamala the first
vp to owe reparations to herself
she could spend the money on a public
speaking class
of course alejandro mayorkas is an
incompetent clown
this guy looks like he should be
assembling christmas toys in the north
pole
not being char being in charge of
immigration
every time i see him i want to pull his
ears like that
weird
rubber doll
[Applause]
by the way that doll has a name it's
panic pete
which i guess beats plato pete
that's a reference to a different story
meanwhile four agents are still to be
punished for using bad language and
unnecessary force something i'm sure
hunter does every time he's with a
hooker sorry these guys are border
patrol agents doing a brutal job they
aren't teachers at a finishing school in
switzerland
but we see the media and dem's true
colors no matter the crisis they only
care when they can find an american
villain 50-plus migrants paris stacked
in the back of a truck
big deal they say but can you imagine if
that happened under trump's watch the
media would have had him pegged as the
driver but today you won't hear biden
say i promise you those people will pay
unless he's advising hunter on how to
cut a deal with a gas company
thank god we have a doctor nearby
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
[Applause]
looks like
looks like joe is rubbing off on the
doctor
and not in the usual way
you think a real-life medical expert
would know the difference between people
and inanimate things
but i guess when you're married to joe
it's hard to tell
i wonder joe what do you think of dr
jill's comments
hey hey hey look look leave my wife
alone she's a doctor all right she'll
get you
and look she's right i've been to those
bogadas they're full of breakfast tacos
and and you know jill got that from me
that's my nickname for the hispanic
people i say
hey come here my little breakfast taco
let me take a whiff of you
oh oh i got sour cream on my nose you
know they like it
they like it uh
you know all the minorities like me i
don't care who you are the latinx people
the malcolm x people they all like me
it's good it's good to laugh but the
treatment of those agents isn't funny at
all it's positively orwellian were
living in 1984. and no wonder joe loves
that year it's when he turns 60.
now the agents could be suspended for 14
days
so you want a dystopian society how
about one that says you're innocent of a
crime but we're going to punish you
anyway
sorry this is america not a porn flick
it's like that old line from the head of
stalin's secret police show me the man
and i'll show you the crime i'd do that
with this guy but we'd be here till
2040.
but all this stuff is happening right
now right before your eyes they're not
even hiding it because they know they
don't have to not with today's
emasculated media if we had a real press
you could not do this real journalists
would know those were reigns on those
horses and not whips and anyone saying
otherwise was a horse's ass
let's welcome
tonight's guests
jeso brainy zombie stalker new york post
business reporter lydia moynihan
[Applause]
well you can't put him in a box
unlike most of his belongings
actor writer and divorced comedian jamie
lisa
well she'll steal your heart and then
your wallet
boxes contributor cat tim
and good luck throwing him under the bus
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus
wyden jill tyrus good to see you by the
way and i love the hat man of a lot of
hats around here so i started changing
it up yeah it's a nice hat yeah it's a
really nice hat thank you you can't have
it's too big for you
i could it would be a boat for you yeah
i could turn it upside down and go
snowboarding yeah was kind of what i
just sledding would have been a better
tournament or boating like i said before
you went there but it's cool you were
hot do your thing no um i didn't hear it
anyway
bogatas have you been to a bogata
no no but i have been to speeches by out
of touch old white women before and
you know what i think this is the result
i'm gonna take a little bit of the heat
off of
the administration this is what happened
when you don't have a good transition of
power i think what happened was is like
i think the trump administration played
some pranks on them i think they took
all the chords for these xerox machines
and left with them so nobody reads
anything they all just wing it and this
is the entire administration has been
winging it they don't know what really
happened
at the border because no one watched the
video right they just told each other
about it so whenever they talk they
don't know the truth they just and then
biden gets up there
and bless his little heart he couldn't
even get horses out yeah
he was like you're going to ride this
and miss this pur
mr ed great show love it like that's
literally because nobody because the
administration took the chords and i
think you should have played the rest of
her
speech because it wasn't she just didn't
call
latin americans breakfast tacos like she
kept going she was like and all my
african-american ribs and my in my
white bags of oatmeal and you know we're
all favorite
fattening food none of us are anything
exciting like like no one got to be
celery or something healthy we were all
like what would i be
what would you be yes if i were a food
if you were a food yes you'd be a
pomegranate why
it's little it's tiny and as soon as it
gets close to your mouth you want to
spit it out
that was pretty quick mm-hmm pretty
quick a lot of hats yeah you do
[Laughter]
you know jamie it's good to see you you
look fit good to see you scooter that's
so weird tyra said that an egg roll cut
me off on the way here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no he deserves it he deserves it he
deserves it i don't care
how did you get divorced again
this was fun right
this is a really fun speech by joe who
are their speech writers each other
what are they doing
do you is it is it true i mean do you
think she mispronounced it because of
being out of touch like we all go to
bode is it because things are delivered
and the i wish she had gone on and on
though like man we went to the bogeta we
uh then we went home and joe mewed the
law one
and
i did the lahandra
like i don't think they do
regular people stuff they don't know
what to say but how weird is it that
they just pretended the video was
different than it was yeah incredible
like we could we could see i always feel
bad when i see like a policeman on a
horse i always wonder does that mean
like you did something wrong
do you know like if you're a really good
copter think oh here's a car and a gun
and then if you're not that good they're
like oh here's a horse in the whip
and
if you really suck they're like here's a
bicycle and a flashlight okay
put all your stuff in the basket i would
rather i would take the desk job over
the horse job right in a second yeah
because you know desk doesn't like you
know
drop the big load
yeah he so
you weren't supposed to make any jokes
about that gut felt yeah but you know
they didn't they didn't catch me
there's usually there's an alarm system
about poop jokes now
and they did i float i'm right under the
radar
lydia you are a reporter
let's start with that i like to think of
myself as such yeah yes
so
in your line of business you would issue
a correction why can't any of these
people admit and they were wrong and
issue their own humanitarian correction
if they will have they ever admitted
they're wrong i mean i think this is
peak 2022 that somebody's cancelled not
for something that they did but for
something that fits someone else's
agenda and i think it's pretty clear the
agenda is that joe biden is not doing
well with hispanic voters he thought
this was the perfect situation to frame
himself as the savior
and the facts didn't line up but you
know that was then and this is now we've
moved on i think my favorite thing from
this whole saga though is the national
association for hispanic journalists
issued a statement condemning jill
biden's remarks
and they ended it with
we are not tacos
yes
there you have it we are not tacos
but cat what if i identify it as a top
you pro you try you probably will i will
i have a
hard shell
but inside there's so many spicy
ingredients all right
a lot of beef all right
all right
no that little boguta blossom breakfast
taco mash-up was one of like the
derangest attempts at a compliment i've
ever heard
and like most of the ones that i get
begin with if i were 50 years younger
well you're not so you probably
shouldn't type those next seven
paragraphs
but
does your wife know you're on here um
but it also proves that in reality the
bidens are not as woke as they pretend
that they are
and they just latch onto certain buzz
words they were like oh this is called
le tinx inclusion but there's an x for
the s perfect i'm gonna go there and say
that i love all my little tacos like
if they actually were paying attention
to these things and not just listening
to what other people are telling them to
say and do then there would not have
been this very strange i don't know
error i don't know what they were trying
to do so i'll just say strange thing
yeah you know i i do think that any time
you try to kowtow to diversity
it's embarrassing because you're
pointing you're actually doing exactly
the opposite of what you're supposed to
go yes i see you're different
you're not supposed to do that you're
not supposed to say that oh i get it
you're different that's why it doesn't
work it makes everybody uncomfortable
all right we got to move on
up next put up your dukes because here
come the news hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else